this gentleman is dynamite and he has
been uh dynamite uh ever since he's come
off the campus at georgia
and he is here as part of the snickers
hungriest player campaign because he's
just been dominating
and he took care of business now for the
eight and three cleveland browns he's
nick chubb how are you nick
i'm good i'm good how are you i am fine
um
boy you are just crushing it nick and uh
i'm wondering how things have changed
from this year to last
for you so far yeah it's been great i
mean
the fun's all in the wind and that's
what we've been doing here so having a
lot of fun this year you know
way more fun i've had the past two years
here getting things done i think i think
it definitely started with the coaches
think um coach defense has done a great
job proving himself as a leader
and we're all following him and he's
just instilled inside of us the only way
to win is to work and that's what we're
doing now
and i mean yeah we have a lot of fun
winning games got to keep it going
well let's let's i'd like to pull on
that thread a little bit here that you
just uh
mentioned about the coaches how's the
the the stefanski staff been different
well i think this for the most part they
um they all came in they're all together
they're all one one unit working
together coaching us
and i think i think the team definitely
follows them and we understand
what coach defensive wants he wants us
to be a team and nothing else let's play
for each other and
to go out there and practice hard every
day do everything right and
it definitely leads to victories on
sundays well he also
um likes to run the football too doesn't
he nick chubb he likes that
yeah and you do as well
three straight 100 yard games nick uh
what's happened in the last three weeks
do you think
for you yeah it's definitely been crazy
because um
three four weeks ago i was i was out i
had a knee injury and
i was pushed right back into it right to
the fire and for me it was
it was definitely more mentally than
physically i knew that my knee was right
but to go out there and
actually get hit in the knee and it was
it was it was great as ever and i knew i
was back to normal and after that i mean
i just took off and the past three weeks
i have been great i mean i think
olan has done a great job blocking
everybody's doing a great job in the run
game
and yeah we have well over a hundred
dollars a game last three games i've
been back for everything
things have been great how about baker
has he's gone four straight games
without an interception first time in
his career how has
how has he improved from your
perspective standing right next to him
all the time yeah yeah burke is great i
mean he's definitely improved a lot and
i think i think one thing that he's
definitely trying to pride himself in
over the last weeks no no turnovers
he's doing a great job taking care of
the ball he's doing a great job making
plays for us
i mean he's definitely he's part of his
offense he makes it go
so uh you know the the concept uh
for for the browns is is simple i guess
just run the ball don't turn it over let
the defense
go to work you guys are eight and three
what are you saying in the locker room
about what you can do
this year 2020 what are you guys talking
about when you get around there
it was we're trying to get better every
day i mean the the games we have one
i mean i feel like like we we could have
done better in all of them i feel like
we definitely left
y'all are going to feel points on the
field i feel like every
every unit offense defense listening we
all can say that
we we can't improve we can't get better
but i mean it is signs
of a good team and still win and not and
not not play its best
i think we are still heading in the
right direction but still so many things
we can clean up
and we still have more potential to be
an even better team no doubt but
what do you what do you think i mean you
know coming up you've got
games against baltimore you've blown out
in week one
i'm sure you'd like to show what you can
do there you're gonna be on the same
field as derek henry the week before
that
pittsburgh at the end of the year i mean
you you have a shot here to make some
considerable hay and win some playoff
games you talking about that right now
nick yeah yeah it's very true but we're
gonna say that one week at a time we're
gonna start the titans
that's that's definitely a huge
challenge for this team i'm sure
everybody's watching because the word
right now is that we can't beat you know
the the great teams
mm-hmm and we're here and we know that
so many it's a great time great chance
for us to
prove can play play with a great team
and how about being on the same field as
derek henry the way that he's playing
too
nick i mean what what is that challenge
for you knowing that you're gonna be
going in a game
against a guy who's just been punking
everybody and going through the whole
last few weeks
what do you think yeah man it's gonna be
great i mean definitely a good challenge
challenge for me and kareem to say that
we can't be as great as you know derek
henry and i'm sure everybody i'm sure be
headlined and all that
but i mean i'm just gonna do what i
always do i'm gonna go out there trust
him believe in myself
i'ma play hard for my team nick chubb
here on the rich eisen show interesting
moments ago you said the team can get
better and that there's always room for
improvement
you actually use the phrase leaving
points on the field nick i think you
know something particular about that
leaving points on the field um stepping
out of bounds
stepping out of bounds with you yeah
having an opportunity to put the ball in
the end zone uh
in terms of uh you know the actual game
sealed it for your team
smart move uh what about fantasy
football players nick did you hear uh
did you hear about that from anybody
nick oh i heard i heard all about it um
my social media dms yeah people were mad
come on
come on come on really they were mad
about it yeah
they were mad they all care about
fantasies they're fantasy owners and
all that all that jazz i mean i really
don't keep up with fantasy
and i didn't know the um the light line
it was a three and three and a half game
point spread or something like that i
had no idea so that's good i found out
about all of it after the game
but at what point in your run down the
field did you
no i'm gonna run about i'm not scoring
i'm gonna run out of bounds right here
at what point i didn't know yeah i
didn't know to that 10 yard line it's
just instinctive
like when i break like that to go score
that's the first time i've ever like not
scored so i didn't even think about it
i was pretty much all the way down there
and i didn't want to
i didn't want to like stop because i
didn't know if i was muhammad he pushed
me in or stripped the ball so i just
kind of made a left turn and went out of
bounds
that's that's that's how it happened why
there's not much time to think
no i know it's instinctive a fellow
georgia bulldog this year
uh todd gurley even when you know
instructed by um
you know his quarterback or the telling
the whole uh
huddle uh matt ryan did it against the
lions don't score even if you have a
chance and he just couldn't help
i mean those things happen so i'm
wondering if you
seeing that helped you lend perspective
to stepping out of bounds in that spot
a little bit i didn't really have time
to think that much about it but i
definitely
i definitely saw that because i coach he
does this thing where
before every week he like he tells him
like what's going on what's going on
around the league
so we can learn from you know the good
and the bad of games happening in nfl so
that that definitely came up
and i did notice it how you know ty he
tried to stop was my minimum character
carried him forward
so i didn't want to be in that situation
somebody behind me could push me in
because the ball had to cross along the
goal line that's it that's right
touchdown so i just i just made a left
and went out of bounds to
prevent any of that from possibly
happening no i know baker's very
confident
uh and confident in his abilities as
well as a team was he confident enough
to tell you in the huddle 59 yards away
don't score
did he tell you that before handing the
ball on that run
well he didn't say that but we have a
cold word that
have that code word and let's let us
know when to score and when not to
okay so i heard i heard that word and i
was like yeah all right
i didn't remember it i was already down
there nick chubb here in the rich eisen
show what do you say to the narrative
everyone thrown out there that you're a
better team without odell
what do you say to that nick no i
definitely don't believe that
i mean we're a good team now we've been
way better with odell
because he just he's electric i mean
he's a you can't you can't replace his
talent and he's really a great player
and then jarvis just did jarvis landry
stuff that we're used to seeing
uh now that he's fully healthy what was
he like in the huddle in that game he
must have been
hyped out of his skull oh in that game
nick oh
100 it was also his birthday his golden
year he's 28 on the 28th
uh whether that day before that so yeah
he he was he was feeling it and he was
looking good i mean
that ball was close anywhere near him he
was catching it and it was it was
definitely amazing to watch
all right nick before i let you go uh
you got the chain do you have the
snickers chain this week
did you get it yes sir i got it what
does it look like describe it to me i've
i've heard others describe it but i'd
love to hear what your take is on it
nick yeah i mean it's incredible it's
made by
ben baller he made he made the same one
last year i mean the first thing i
noticed how
funny and how shiny this pretty it was
and then i picked it up and this thing
was heavy
like really heavy well i mean the others
who have won it this year josh jacobs
aaron jones
um another chub bradley chubb tyler
lockett aj brown
dalvin cook kyler murray davonte adam
you're in very good company nick shub
you're in very good yeah i know i
started lift my thoughts i wasn't i was
in great company and
all those guys are ballista i'm happy to
be right there with them what is your
who was your running uh running back
growing up who are you like i want to be
like him i want to get to the nfl and
run like him who is that guy
nick for you uh honestly i didn't really
have like one guy who always watched i
mean i could give you like
the answer everybody gives me everybody
was an agent peterson fan
okay it's still crazy that i watched
them in high school now i'm playing with
them
but yeah asian picture scene was great
marshawn lynch and beastmode i enjoyed
watching all those guys
okay i don't want terrell davis to get
pissed off you know so
i gotta throw some georgia in there too
right or actually if you want to piss
off
uh terrell davis say heinz ward was your
running back grown up that's the
oh yeah he went like that
that's the guy you know that that's the
guy um all right uh thanks for the call
nick i appreciate the time
thank you yeah no problem thanks for
having me all right thanks for the call
that's nick
everybody check out his social media and
follow the hashtag snickerschain on
social to see which player gets it
each week throughout the season that is
awarded to the league's hungriest player
every week that's nick chubb here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here